Nein, ich wollte eigentlich nie
einen Freund oder Mann
aus einem anderen Land,
weil ich mir das
so schwierig vorstellte.
Ich bin überzeugt, es wird auf der
ganzen Welt Frauen wie Lana geben.
Das ist ja das Schöne:
Liebe kennt keine Grenzen.
Man kann
alle Verrücktheiten ausleben.
* Herzschläge *
* Romantische Melodie *
# Take my hand, take me anywhere,
as long as you are there.
# Take my hand.
# Together we will be
forever you and me.
* Fröhliche Mariachi-Musik *
Let's go.
Do the first step.
- Okay.
(Bienvenidos.)
(Ich bin in Mexiko unterwegs,
genauer gesagt, in Monterrey,
zu Besuch beim Schweizer Demis und
seiner mexikanischen Frau Nancy.)
(Und für mich gibt es jetzt
die mexikanische Feuertaufe.)
Que tal? Como estas?
Todo bien? Muy tranquilo.
Soy Mona.
Ja, ja, ja. Oh la, la.
Na!
- Die kannst du so abbeissen.
Abbeissen?
- Ja. Den Stiel lässt du dran.
Ja, und dann?
- Den Stiel schmeisst du weg.
No pasa nada, amigo.
- Wuah, fuck!
Ya es mexicana.
Jetzt bist du Mexikanerin.
Danke. Muchas gracias.
(Das mit dem scharfen Essen
ist nicht nur ein Klischee.)
(Aber sonst stimmt einiges nicht
am Bild von Mexiko,
das man als Schweizer im Kopf hat.)
(Demis ging es anfangs genauso.)
Damals kannte ich nur
die Trickfilme: "Speedy Gonzales".
Ich dachte, die tragen Sombreros
und den ganzen Tag einen Poncho.
Als ich zu reisen begann -
zuerst in Asien -
durfte ich
viele Mexikaner kennenlernen.
Und ich durfte auch
mit Mexikanern zusammenarbeiten,
damals bei der UBS.
Ich merkte: Das sind so lebensfrohe
und glückliche Menschen.
Ich möchte mich
von dieser Kultur anstecken lassen.
(Das ist jetzt über sechs Jahre her.)
Wie ist das eigentlich?
Ich weiss nicht,
ob das nur wegen der Kamera ist,
dass alle sagen,
du seist schon ein echter Mexikaner.
In welchen Situationen
warst du doch ein Ausländer,
hast du gemerkt,
dass du doch kein Mexikaner bist?
Ein Blonder wird hier
halt als Gott betrachtet.
Giltst du als Blonder?
Wenn ich hier durch den Markt laufe,
nennen Sie mich schon "Blonder".
Blonder? Wieso das?
Weil ich eine hellere
Haut- und Augenfarbe habe.
Das ist eine Ehre, wenn jemand aus
den USA oder aus Europa herkommt.
Ja. Aber wie ist es umgekehrt?
Wie ist es in der Schweiz?
Empfindest du es gleich?
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Als ich das erste Mal in der Schweiz
war, fühlte ich mich sehr allein.
Niemand hat mich gegrüsst,
niemand nahm mich wahr.
Ich fühlte mich allein
und habe geweint.
Die Vorstellung,
in der Schweiz zu leben ...
Nein, ich würde verrückt.
Si, de verdad, lo he intentado.
Wer hat hier die Hosen an? Sie.
Sie will nicht in der Schweiz leben,
also muss ich hier leben.
Nimm nur ein bisschen!
Salud. Auf Mexiko.
- Viva Mexico.
* Gemütliche Gitarrenmusik *
* Fröhliche Tanzmusik *
Anfangs habe ich oft
mit ihm gestritten, sogar zu oft.
Er wollte nie teilen.
Ich aber schon.
Das gehört für mich
zwingend zum Leben dazu.
Teilen ist für mich alles.
Ich war total kalkuliert, als ob ich
noch in einer Finanzwelt wäre,
in der ich schauen muss:
"Rentiert das, was wir ihm geben?"
"Da kommt aber gar nichts zurück."
* Gemütliche Gitarrenmusik *
(Das, was man hat,
mit anderen teilen,
auch als Akt der Nächstenliebe.)
(Das leben Nancy und ihre Familie
ganz konkret.)
(Zweimal pro Woche kochen sie
für ca. 200 Bedürftige
und Obdachlose von Monterrey.)
Das Fleisch wird hinten angekocht.
Denn sonst
erwärmt sich das Haus zu schnell.
(Ein richtiges Familienprojekt.
Alle helfen mit.)
Ja.
Esto es picante?
- Es muy picante, no?
Willst du probieren?
- Nein, danke.
Wir dachten, wenn wir den anderen
helfen, geht es ihnen besser.
Aber in Wirklichkeit geht es uns
besser, wenn wir anderen helfen.
* Sanftes Glockenspiel *
Aqui hay lugar, si quieres.
Quieres darme los ...
* Gemütliche Gitarrenmusik *
(Monterrey liegt im Norden Mexikos,
nur 2 Std. von der
amerikanischen Grenze entfernt.)
(Eine Stadt
mit über 4 Mio. Einwohnern.)
(Seit bald fünf Jahren
verteilt Familie Cortez hier
selbst gekochtes Essen.)
(Finanziell geht es der Familie gut.)
(Diesen Aufwand jedenfalls
können und wollen sie sich leisten.)
Gracias.
- Gracias.
Vamos!
(Sie begannen damit nach dem Tod
von Erick, Nancys Bruder.)
(Inzwischen ist es eine Tradition,
die der ganzen Familie
beim Verarbeiten dieses
schweren Schicksalsschlags hilft.)
(Dass es hier
ein warmes Gratisabendessen gibt,
hat sich sogar bei der Polizei
rumgesprochen.)
Dos, eh?
- Si.
* Nachdenkliche, pulsierende Klänge *
(Es ist eine schöne,
friedliche Atmosphäre hier.)
(Und ich kann nachempfinden,
dass so ein Abend
Balsam für die Seele aller ist.)
Es war ja nicht so, dass Lana
gezwungen wurde, mich zu heiraten.
Ich habe mich in sie verliebt
und sie sich in mich.
Ich habe dann den Vorschlag gemacht,
sie solle in die Schweiz kommen.
Sie fragte: "Wie? Als Freundin, als
Mätresse, als Verlobte, als Frau?"
Da sagte ich: "Ja, wir heiraten."
Mit dem Katalog,
quasi auf dem Präsentierteller
war es halt einfacher zu sagen:
"Dieser und jener Charakterzug
und das ..."
Das kann man so zusammenstellen.
Und das ist gut so.
* Gemütliche Gitarrenmelodie *
* Sie spricht russisch. *
(Familie Krättli
macht Platz für Besuch.)
(Lanas Mutter Anastasia
kommt aus der Ukraine nach Thusis.)
* Sie spricht russisch. *
Manchmal
spricht sie einfach russisch.
Manchmal verstehe ich etwas.
Hatte ich jetzt russisch gesprochen?
- Ja, ja.
Puh!
(Russisch)
(Englisch)
Can you stand there and tell me
and see if it's in the middle?
Ah, ja, ja.
Ich möchte sie
so gerne in den Arm nehmen.
Sie ist
ein bisschen kleiner als ich.
Ich mag ihren Geruch in meiner Nase.
Sie ist jetzt schon 72
und noch sehr selbstständig.
In meiner Familie
ist sie der General.
(Geplant ist, dass Anastasia
eine Weile in der Schweiz bleibt.)
(Das hat natürlich Auswirkungen
auf das ganze Familienleben.)
Das Problem ist ja nicht, dass wir
uns wahnsinnig oft sehen würden.
Wenn man einander oft sieht, geht
man einander eher auf die Nerven.
Sie war ja jetzt ...
ich weiss nicht ...
... über ein Jahr nicht mehr da.
Die Idee ist,
dass sie drei Monate hier bleibt.
Aber das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Ich bin ja auch relativ beschäftigt
und immer wieder weg.
Wir können ja auch nicht wahnsinnig
gut miteinander kommunizieren,
denn sie kann etwas Englisch,
ich nur wenig Russisch.
Das ist schwierig. Aber
wir kommen gut aneinander vorbei.
Sie ist also kein Schwiegermonster.
Überhaupt nicht.
Das müssen wir alles rausräumen.
* Nachdenkliche Gitarrenmusik *
(Zwar sind Lana und ihre Mutter jeden
Tag per Skype miteinander in Kontakt,
aber sich endlich wieder
richtig nahe sein können,
ist noch mal etwas ganz anderes.)
* Sie spricht russisch. *
(Anastasia
ist zum sechsten Mal in der Schweiz.)
(Als erstes Highlight
wünscht sie sich jeweils Fisch
im Flughafenrestaurant.)
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
(Nicht immer
ist alles reibungslos abgelaufen.)
(Es habe auch schon Streit gegeben
bei diesen Besuchen.)
Ich freue mich jetzt,
drei Monate hier sein zu können.
Aber wir müssen uns
ein bisschen zusammenreissen.
Wir werden uns Mühe geben müssen.
Wir haben das vorher besprochen,
und abgemacht,
dass wir uns mit unserem Charakter
und den Emotionen zurückhalten.
Denn zwei Frauen in einer Küche -
das kann schwierig werden.
Nein, alles wird gut, Mama.
Gib mir deine Hand!
Ich bin ja schon älter und brauche
einfach etwas Aufmerksamkeit.
Ja, ich habe schon
mit Martin gesprochen.
Wir haben jetzt
nicht nur einen Sohn,
sondern eine Tochter,
um die wir uns kümmern müssen.
Nein, eine Oma.
* Fröhliche Zupfmelodie *
Hallo!
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Welcome! Hallo. Alles gut?
Good flight? Alles okay?
Auto? Car? Alles gut?
Okay, super.
- Super.
Sehr gut. Great.
* Sanfte Zithermelodie *
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Qu'est-ce que j'aime?
J'aime son ...
- Le plus.
Ich liebe seine
ruhige und intelligente Seite.
Ich finde seine Intelligenz sexy.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
(Es sind erst
einige Wochen vergangen,
seit Thomas Kleiber zum letzten Mal
vom "Meteo"-Dach des Schweizer
Fernsehen heruntergestiegen
und zu seinem Mann David
nach Quebec gezogen ist.)
(Thomas ist immer noch dabei,
diese Stadt im französischen Teil
Kanadas zu entdecken.)
(Hier, am deutschen Weihnachtsmarkt,
kommt er sich etwas heimisch vor.)
* Im Hintergrund
läuft "O Tannenbaum" *
Es ist eigentlich gleich.
Sogar die Lieder sind auf Deutsch.
Anscheinend sind sie stolz
auf den deutschen Weihnachtsmarkt.
Auch wenn es - und das ist natürlich
ganz schwach - keinen Glühwein gibt.
Aber hier darf man auf der Strasse
keinen Alkohol trinken.
(Im Hintergrund, Chor ab Band)
# ... nicht nur zur Sommerzeit,
# nein, auch im Winter ...
- ... wenn es schneit.
# O Tannenbaum ...
Endlich verstehe ich Französisch.
* Kirchenglocken *
(Was Thomas hier in Quebec genau
machen will, steht noch nicht fest.)
(Er muss sich erst mal
neu orientieren.)
(Schliesslich
hat er gerade erst für die Liebe
seinen Beruf, seine Familie, Freunde
und sein Land zurückgelassen.)
(Zum Spaziergang
gehört eine Pause im Subtil,
dem Cafe, das von Davids Familie
betrieben wird.)
(David arbeitet im Moment hier:
Er managed das Cafe
und stellt den ganzen Betrieb
gerade auf Nachhaltigkeit um.)
Grüezi.
- Grüezi. - Einen Kaffee, bitte.
Ja, kein Problem.
(Vielleicht ist Thomas
hier bald nicht mehr nur Kunde.)
Ich kann es mir schon vorstellen.
Zu Beginn werde ich
wohl eher Tellerwäscher sein.
Dann zum Tassenwäscher aufsteigen,
vielleicht auch Gabeln und Messer.
Nein, zu Beginn werde ich sicher
das Allereinfachste machen.
Und dann mit der Zeit, glaube ich,
werde ich vielleicht
auch Essen zubereiten.
Das wird sich zeigen.
Aber das wäre ein guter Job zum
Überbrücken und Französisch lernen.
Aber wohl nur halbtags.
Mein Hirn hält das keinen Tag durch.
So mache ich etwas Sinnvolles,
helfe der Familie.
Ich wohne bei ihnen.
Sie haben mir viel gegeben.
So kann ich etwas zurückgeben
und erhielte etwas Taschengeld.
Dann müsste ich nicht immer David
schöne Augen machen,
wenn ich ein Bier
trinken gehen will.
(Thomas
hat zwei Studiengänge abgeschlossen:
Chemie und Umweltwissenschaften.)
(Mit diesem Rucksack
sollte es auch in Kanada
interessante Perspektiven geben.)
Ich gab meinen Traumberuf auf,
weil es einfach zu repetitiv wurde.
Es gab zu wenige
neue Herausforderungen.
Ich brauche Herausforderungen,
Abwechslung,
ich schaffe gerne Neues,
probiere aus.
Manchmal hat man selber
nicht genug Fantasie,
um zu kapieren,
was das Leben einem alles gibt.
Dann überrascht es einem
plötzlich und man denkt:
"Cool, das ist ja besser,
als ich es mir vorgestellt hatte."
Zu 98 % sind die Menschen hier
total glücklich,
dass ein Schweizer
aus seiner perfekten Welt in
der Schweiz nach Mexiko gekommen ist
und sagt: "Mexiko ist cool,
ich fühle mich hier zu Hause."
Und viele Mexikaner fühlen sich
durch meine Lebensfreude
hier in Mexiko angesteckt.
Sie entdecken ihr eigenes Mexiko neu
durch die Augen eines Schweizers.
* Rassige mexikanische Musik *
(In Mexiko ist heute
Dia de los Muertos, Tag der Toten.)
(Bei uns Allerseelen.)
(Wir sind auf dem Weg nach Patzcuaro
und offensichtlich
nicht die Einzigen.)
Wir müssen alle beieinander bleiben,
sonst haben wir uns
das letzte Mal gesehen.
Lourdes ist nichts im Vergleich.
Und nach einem besinnlichen Abend
sieht es auch nicht unbedingt aus.
Ist neben uns
eigentlich ganz Mexiko hier?
Auf den Fotos sieht es immer aus,
als wäre es halb leer
mit tollem Licht.
Aber die Details
werden auf Instagram nie gezeigt.
* Mona lacht. *
Also ...
(Der Toten gedenken -
so geht das also auf Mexikanisch.)
(Der Dia de los Muertos ist einer
der wichtigsten Feiertage Mexikos.)
(Und dank dem Trickfilm "Coco"
kennt jetzt die ganze Welt das Fest.)
(Vermutlich sind auch deshalb
so viele Touristen hier.)
* Sie trällern ein fröhliches Lied
im Chor. *
Auf der Suche
nach einem besinnlichen Abend
sind wir am Oktoberfest von Mexiko
gelandet.
Ya esta. Un, dos, tres.
- Aqui es Patzcuaro ...
(Und natürlich können Nancy und Demis
als echte Influencer
der Versuchung nicht widerstehen.)
(Denn wo, wenn nicht hier,
findet man solch bunte
und verrückte Bilder und Szenen?)
Puedo tomar una foto contigo?
- Si, claro.
Es que yo te sigo.
- Hola, mucho gusto.
(Und wenn man dann auch noch
auf Fans trifft, umso schöner.)
Haben sie euch gekannt?
Ja, sie wusste, dass wir
eben noch in der Schweiz waren.
Total süss.
Sie folgt unseren Videos.
Ihr habt so richtige Fans hier.
You're famous.
* Nancy jauchzt. *
Her more than me.
- Ay, no.
No. Ja, es ist schon süss.
In Mexiko kennen einen
die Leute auf der Strasse.
Wir sehen
auch etwas ungewöhnlich aus.
Ich mit den langen Haaren, dem Bart,
sie in ihrem mexikanischen Stil
mit den farbenfrohen Kleidern.
Es ist schön, wenn man
für seine Arbeit anerkannt wird.
(Wir lassen den Trubel
des berühmten Patzcuaro hinter uns
und gehen zu einem anderen,
kleineren Friedhof.)
(Hier sind Instagram oder YouTube
nicht mehr wichtig.)
(Hier denkt Nancy nur noch an
ihren Bruder Erick, der mit 19 starb
und daran,
wie sie sein Grab schmücken würde.)
(Seit dem Tod ihres jüngeren Bruders
vor fünf Jahren
hat Nancy es noch nicht geschafft,
den Dia de los Muertos zu feiern.)
(Die Erinnerungen
schmerzen immer noch zu sehr.)
Gracias por entender
que no queria estar ahi.
Que si, esta muy bonito.
* Sie murmeln untereinander. *
... disfrutar este presente
que tenemos.
Maybe, I don't know how ...
Ich weiss nicht,
wie ich reagieren würde,
was ich nicht aufgeben würde
für die Liebe.
Ach, das kannst du dann haben
wie ein Dachdecker:
mit oder ohne Ziegel.
Das ist mir dann egal.
I know, I'm bad.
- Yeah.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmelodie *
(-33 °C, der Winter
von Monatana ist gnadenlos.)
(Weil manchmal
sogar der Strom ausfällt,
ist ein Feuer überlebenswichtig.)
(Jay und Brigitte
sind es sich gewohnt.)
(Seit acht Jahren
leben sie jetzt schon
zusammen hier in diesem Trailer.)
Like that for a minute.
Careful now when you're on the bed.
- Mhm.
Das sind Adlerfedern.
Wenn man Adlerfedern braucht,
muss man ein Gesuch stellen
und beweisen,
dass man Native American ist.
Dass man also Stammeszugehöriger
ist, eine Stammeskarte hat.
Ich darf keine Adlerfedern haben.
Ich habe zwar einen Fächer
mit Adlerfedern,
der aber offiziell seiner ist.
Ich benutze ihn einfach. Aber
als Weisse darf ich keine haben.
Ich habe mich
sicher insofern verändert,
als dass ich
etwas lockerer geworden bin.
Ich habe einen Mann,
der sehr viele Jokes macht.
Joking about everything.
Zu Beginn
war ich richtig schweizerisch,
so, wie wir charakterlich eben sind.
Ich musste wirklich lernen,
aufgeschlossener zu sein,
to take it more easily.
Heute bin ich so weit, dass ich bei
vielem, bei dem ich vorher noch ...
Blow up.
Vorher nahm ich es zu persönlich,
nicht nur als Joke.
Damit kann ich heute
viel besser umgehen.
Wenn er stichelt,
stichle ich zurück.
(Brigitte hat vieles dazugelernt,
seit sie mit Jay verheiratet ist.)
(Manchmal war es schwierig, meist
fanden sich die beiden aber schnell.)
(Besonders, wenn es um Jays
indianischen Hintergrund ging.)
(Damit konnte sich Brigitte
sofort identifizieren.)
Leave them there until we go.
- Yeah, good idea.
Alright?
- Yes.
That's all. The coffee is in here.
- Okay.
We could stop
and get some on the way, right?
Yeah.
Das ist der neue Schild,
den sie für mich gemacht hat. Cool.
Früher hätte man das mit dickem Le-
der überzogen, um Pfeile abzuhalten.
Heutzutage ist es blosse Dekoration.
Brigitte fragte,
ob sie es überziehen solle.
Aber ich fand es nicht nötig.
Wir haben viele Komplimente
gekriegt,
als Brigitte das online stellte.
(Die zwei machen sich bereit
für die Reise an ein Powwow,
einem traditionellen Treffen
der nordamerikanischen Indianer.)
(Selbstverständlich gehören
die entsprechenden Kleider dazu.)
Das ist jetzt mein Kleid.
Das hier sind künstliche elk teeth,
also keine echten.
Denn originale wären aus Elfenbein.
Und ein Elch hat zwei davon.
Ich bin nicht ganz sicher,
ob das beim männlichen
oder weiblichen Tier so ist.
Je mehr elk teeth man am Kleid hat,
desto besser
ist der Mann oder Vater -
wer auch immer in der Familie -
im Jagen.
Das rührt daher.
Careful, honey.
- Mhm.
(Vor dem Powwow gehen sie noch
bei Jays Bruder Darby vorbei.)
(Sie haben 7 Std. Fahrt vor sich.)
(Genau wie damals, als Brigitte
Jays Familie erstmals getroffen hat.)
Das war im Sommer 2010.
Ja.
Ich war aufgeregt, nervös -
wie man halt ist,
wenn man die Familie
zum ersten Mal sieht.
Wir wussten damals ja noch nicht
100%ig ... Er schon, er wusste es.
Aber ich war noch nicht sicher,
ob das wirklich klappt.
Ja.
Come on, sweetie. Time to go.
Are you in?
- Yeah.
Well, sweetie, you be good.
I won't have to spank you.
* Verträumte Gitarrenmusik *
Auf dieser Internetseite
gab es ein Forum,
da äusserten Experten,
die schon viel mehr wussten,
ihre Meinung über die ukrainischen
und russischen Frauen.
Da zeigte sich mehrheitlich,
dass diese Frauen
eher noch etwas genügsamer sind
als Schweizerinnen oder Deutsche.
Dass die Frauen in Mitteleuropa
eher eine Karriere anstreben
und die Frauen in der Ukraine
noch eher dazu bereit sind,
Hausfrauen zu sein.
Lana ist jetzt zwar Hausfrau,
aber sie würde auch gerne arbeiten.
Aber eben, wir teilen.
Ich will ein Plus machen
für die Familie.
In meinem ukrainischen Leben,
habe ich alles selber gemacht.
Ukrainische Männer, äh, äh.
In meinem Leben
war da immer nur ich.
* Glockenläuten *
* Sanfte Zithermusik *
(Es ist kurz vor Weihnachten.)
(Lanas Mutter ist schon seit
drei Wochen in Thusis zu Besuch.)
(Und immer noch sind die beiden
ein Herz und eine Seele.)
(Zumindest meistens.)
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Ich hatte mir
anfangs Sorgen gemacht,
dass unsere
unterschiedlichen Charaktere
erneut aufeinanderprallen könnten.
Wir sind halt wie Wildschweine.
Wir sind beide
im Jahr des Schweins geboren.
Mutter ist ein Leittier
und ich bin eines.
Und wir geben nicht nach.
Aber jetzt
haben wir Frieden geschlossen.
* Fröhliche Musik *
* Sie spricht russisch. *
Wow!
- Wow! Cool!
Krasiii...
- Krasiva.
Sehr schön.
Es sieht super aus.
Ich könnte das nicht.
Ja. Sieht genial aus. Sehr schön.
Bravo.
- Okay, enough.
I ya!
I ya.
* Sanfte Zithermusik *
Tight!
Oh, Martin, I'm scared.
* Martin lacht. *
Ja, ja. So, let's go.
* Erschrockener Aufschrei *
It's important
not to go to the back, okay?
Martin, I'm scared. So you go first.
Warte! Ui!
Ui! Uii!
* Sie lachen. *
(Weil die Grossmutter
auf den kleinen Leon aufpasst,
können Martin und Lana
endlich wieder einmal
etwas zu zweit unternehmen.)
Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass wir mal
Zeit nur für uns gefunden haben,
hier auf dem Eisfeld.
Ohne Schüler und ohne unseren Sohn.
Sonst sähe das so aus
wie bei denen da hinten.
Aber so kann ich mich wieder mal
wie ein kleines Mädchen fühlen
und nicht wie eine alte Tante.
* Leise Popmusik
schallt über das Feld. *
Wow! I love you more and more.
Ay!
* Sie kichert. *
So, let's go together.
- These skates are ...
Böh, Katastrophe.
(Diese Momente als Paar
vermisst Lana manchmal.)
(Obwohl es ihr hier gefällt,
hat die Lehrerin aus der Ukraine
in der Schweiz
noch nicht so richtig Anschluss.)
Für sie ist es sehr schwierig.
Ich bewundere das.
Ich könnte nie
in ein anderes Land gehen,
alles hinter mir lassen
und dort neu beginnen.
Sie muss zurückstecken.
Denn sie hat eigentlich
auch eine sehr gute Ausbildung,
kann diese hier
aber nicht einsetzen,
weil sie hier nicht anerkannt ist.
Sie muss im Prinzip hinten anstehen,
zu Hause bleiben,
und ich mache die Arbeit.
Das ist für sie auch schwer, weil
sie sich früher selber ernährt hat.
* Sie summen die Melodie
zu "My Heart Will Go On" *
* Fröhliche Popmusik *
Für mich war es ein Segen,
ihn kennengelernt zu haben.
Er hat mir eine neue Welt eröffnet,
meinen kleinen sozialen Kreis
gesprengt,
alles, woran ich glaubte.
Demis kam und sagte:
"Schau mal, das alles gibt es."
Ich war Gott sehr dankbar.
Alles, was ich mir gewünscht habe,
traf ein.
Ich war sehr verliebt.
Und jetzt kann ich meinen Weg gehen
und er seinen.
Denn wir sind beide frei.
* Fröhliche Mariachi-Musik *
(Das ist Nancys Elternhaus.)
(Hier wohnt sie jetzt mit Demis,
wenn sie nicht gerade
irgendwo auf Reisen sind.)
(Malen
ist Nancys grosse Leidenschaft.)
(Mittlerweile verdient sie auch Geld
mit ihrer Kunst.)
(Ich mache mit Demis einen
Spaziergang durch das Quartier.)
(Im Gegensatz zu einigen
anderen Gegenden in der Stadt
kann man sich hier
relativ gut frei bewegen.)
Werden diese Hunde
zur Sicherheit gehalten?
Ja, meistens schon.
Denn es geht niemand
mit den Hunden spazieren.
Du bist der Einzige.
- Das tun sonst wenige.
* Wütendes Bellen *
Es ist ein grosser Unterschied:
Der Norden Mexikos, so nahe
der Grenze zur USA, und der Süden.
Im Süden schlafen die Menschen z.T.
bei offener Tür, haben keine Gitter.
Im Norden ist es also weniger sicher?
Ja, durch den Norden geht auch
der Weg der Drogen in die USA.
Wir sind 2 Std.
von der Grenze entfernt.
Also besteht hier
ein grösserer Interessenskonflikt
bei den Kartellen
und wegen der Migration.
Nach dem weissen Auto.
(Als Demis hier einzog,
begannen Nancys Eltern
für die beiden das Haus umzubauen.)
Das mit der Baubewilligung
ist hier nicht so ein Problem.
Man macht, was man will.
Und wir machten
aus dem Balkon ein Zimmer.
Okay.
You already explained it?
- Yes.
This was the balcony.
- The balcony, no, amor?
Das ist sehr romantisch.
Zusammen am Boden schlafen,
das ist die Definition
von immer noch sehr verliebt sein.
Fühlst du dich hier zu Hause?
Ja, ich bin gerne hier.
Ich kann mir aber auch
ein Leben anderswo vorstellen.
Ich spüre,
meine Eltern sind nun dafür bereit.
Der nächste Schritt ist,
dass wir eine Wohnung mieten wollen.
Du möchtest nun deine eigene Familie?
- Ja, ich fühle mich bereit.
Möchten deine Eltern Enkel?
Ja, sicher.
- Ja.
They are telling you: "Please!"
- "Please, pleasse, please!"
Sie sagen dann: "Wir sind dann
mal weg für die nächsten 5 Std."
Dann fragen wir uns: "Was ist los?"
Dann gehen wir schlafen und im
Zimmer brennt schon rotes Licht.
"Okay, cool, dass sie schon alles
für uns vorbereitet haben."
Also machen quasi die Schwiegereltern
eure Familienplanung.
Ja, sie wären
schon gerne Grosseltern.
* Sanfte Melodie *
(Heute ist mein letzter Abend
bei Familie Cortez.)
(Wir feiern das
mit einem guten Essen.)
... que bendiga mi hogar y todos los
que entren por la puerta.
Que bendiga esta comida
en el nombre de Jesus Cristo, amen.
(Alle) Amen.
- Buen provecho!
Gracias por cocinar.
- Gracias.
Gracias por cocinar, si.
- (Mutter) Mona tambien cocino.
Wo werde ich euch
in fünf Jahren treffen?
Ich würde gerne in Mexiko bleiben.
Aber um Kinder
und ein Haus zu haben,
wäre mir der Süden Mexikos lieber.
Der Staat ist etwas günstiger
und auch authentischer.
Und reisen wollen wir
zwischen Europa und Mexiko.
Schweiz, Spanien, Italien -
v.a. in die Schweiz.
Ihr bleibt Reisende.
- Hauptsache kein Winter.
Es perfecto, si.
Aber Mexiko wird unsere Basis sein.
Salud!
- (Alle) Salud!
Viva Mexico!
* Jubel *
Salud, salud! Y muchas gracias.
* Ruhige Gitarrenmelodie *
(Zurück nach Quebec,
in Thomas Kleibers neues Zuhause,
im ehemaligen Kinderzimmer
seines Mannes David.)
(Seit er in Kanada ist,
schreibt Thomas einen Blog.)
Auf schoggichueche.com erzähle ich
einfach aus meinem Alltag.
Manchmal auch über das Wetter -
ich kann nicht anders.
Und über Land und Leute
und darüber, was ich erlebe.
Ich denke, es soll einerseits
etwas informativ sein,
und andererseits auch etwas witzig.
Ich bin jetzt nicht der
todernsteste Mensch auf der Welt.
Es ist schon sehr schweizerisch,
zu denken, ich mache jetzt
drei Monate lang nichts.
Also ich arbeite nicht. Meine Güte!
Ich habe mein ganzes Leben ge-
arbeitet, habe immer etwas gemacht.
Was soll der Druck?
Ich merke, dass ich das
sehr verinnerlicht habe.
Man muss immer, immer etwas machen,
was man nach aussen
gut verkaufen kann.
Was denkst du?
* Schnurren *
Eben.
Ja. Uh!
(Nächste Woche besuche ich Thomas
Kleiber im frostigen Winter Quebecs.)
* Sie lacht. *
Man beginnt plötzlich,
sich Sorgen über die private
und berufliche Zukunft zu machen.
Anfangs hatte ich Mühe,
war super nervös.
Ich dachte:
"Wie wird das? Ich als Weisse!"
We will go.
(Martin und Lana
planen eine grosse Reise.)
Wenn sie das Visum nicht bekommt,
dann muss ich eben allein gehen.
(Nächsten Freitag
sind wir wieder hin und weg.)
# Hey. Take my hand.